and what more can the british government
do to try to help the people of ukraine
at this their most desperate hour
well it's it's just truly appalling
isn't it the unfolding atrocities that
we're
seeing now
every day
are just so breaking and
things that we just never thought that
we would see again in our lifetimes on
our doorstep and it's it's absolutely
appalling
and you know the international community
with britain playing it its leading role
we need to retain
um that that unity of strength uh unity
of strength in our vow to bring those to
justice for war crimes and for these
atrocities uh unity
in strength in terms of sanctions which
still could go further we we want the
british government to
close down many of the loopholes and
some of the trusts and some of the other
things that exist uh that mean that the
sanctions aren't quite being as
effective as they could here in the uk
um and united in that strength in terms
of uh providing and continue to provide
military aid
to the ukrainian
people and armies as as well which has
actually been very effective to date but
could go further and could go faster
let me bring you back to domestic
politics if i may of course you've been
hearing overnight um sort of tea time
yesterday that the government is
planning to sell channel four i spoke to
a previous culture secretary jeremy hunt
and asked him whether he would have
considered selling channel 4 when he was
in the hot seat let's listen to what he
had to say if you'll indulge us and then
i'd love to get your response to that
here we go
i look i'm not against privatization in
in other contexts but what i'm in favor
of is is competition
and i think that we have very high
standard of broadcasting in this country
because we have competition not just in
the the very popular uh soap operas and
box sets and and series that uh
are going to be commercially very
successful but we also have competition
in other areas like news and
documentaries
which are not likely to be commercially
viable and that's i think it's really
important to maintain that competition
and i do think channel 4 is part of that
ecosystem
he also told me his panel that he would
never he didn't even contemplate selling
um channel 4 when he was culture
secretary your thoughts on the
suggestions from nadine doris this
morning that that's the way forward
well i mean i think i agree with with
jeremy hunt there i just don't see
what the case is
uh for selling off uh channel four i
mean not notwithstanding that it's just
not anybody's priority right now there's
plenty of other things that the
government should be getting on with
like dealing with the cost of living um
crisis and so on but channel four is a
non-for-profit publicly owned uh
broadcasting uh company whose remit is
very specific and and special and unique
in the uk in that it's there to support
small independent production companies
it doesn't own the ip itself it doesn't
own those programs itself and so that
nurtures and allows lots of small
businesses to develop particularly
outside of london and channel 4 do a
great deal in terms of investing in that
leveling up agenda as well so i just
don't understand why they're doing it
nobody's in favor of it the the industry
is not in favor of channel 4 itself
isn't in favor i the public are quite
happy with things uh as they are so it
really does feel like a the wrong
decision at the wrong time and you know
it feels like it is a cultural vandalism
um a bit of a vendetta if you like
against some of the news output that the
government just doesn't like
um talk to me about the cancer care
report um that we're going to be hearing
more about today the way you're speaking
to us from this morning the northwest
liverpool particularly
has got the most challenges when it
comes
to cancer cases in the whole
of england
it looks as though potentially we're
moving backwards when it comes to
treating cancer what do you
what does labour put that down to
well look i mean
we have we we've historically have
always had some of the
the worst cancer treatment um uh rates
we rece in recent times we've reversed
that trend and we've seen and treated
people much more quickly obviously the
last labor government brought in very
fast targets for cancer treatment and
diagnosis which absolutely uh sped up
the the system and dealt with with some
of those um those deep inequalities in
in terms of care that we we had
historically uh been seeing there's no
question that the uh the pandemic and
what we saw in terms of the nhs has put
huge set that backwards really there's
no question that people
didn't go to hospital perhaps didn't go
to see their doctor in in early stages
when they had worries they had concerns
and and that's going to have a have a
lag as well and obviously the nhs is is
dealing with a huge uh backlog here and
it hasn't got the staff it hasn't got
the resources that it needs to to really
deal with uh to deal with those all-time
high waiting list that it's now got and
that's obviously going to have a
dramatic effect on on things like cancer
care and other areas as well
i don't know if you heard um the whale
secretary was on the program uh
yesterday
saying the world's moved on and as far
as partygate is concerned the prime
minister will be staying in post as he
should
i would clip that up on twitter more
than half a million people viewed that
on my twitter feed yesterday as you can
imagine it was a a myriad of different
comments what's your view
well
i mean people won't forget partygate
that easily i'm afraid i mean the
government might want to brush it under
the carpet
um but it really matters it really
matters because of the sacrifices that
everybody else made in not
seeing their loved ones in not attending
funerals and not seeing people who were
dying in in hospital or or being able to
see grandchildren born that they hadn't
even met for the first year of their
lives those sacrifices are absolutely
enormous that people took and what we've
seen unfolding is that the very people
who made those rules and who told us to
behave in that way
weren't following the same rules the
senior
civil servants in downing street
politicians in downing street
others in downing street who were
engaging in in serial
social uh gatherings and activities
otherwise known as as as parties um at a
time when we were all making those
sacrifices so i think you know the
government ministers can i'm sure
continue to come on your program and try
and brush that under the carpet but the
public just won't forgive that and and
the public wants to see some
accountability for that and not just uh
pretending that it's not existing and
saying sorry there's more important
issues for us to be thinking about
it's two years uh yesterday since
kierstenberg became the labour leader
since then we've had partygate
we've had 166 000 deaths uh directly uh
accountable to covid we're told and the
government are doing u-turn after u-turn
after u-turn but labour is still only a
few points ahead in the opinion polls
why is that
well i think i think when kia became
leader two years ago we were something
like 15 points behind in the opinion
polls or some very large double-digit
um figure
so i think by any sort of um suggestion
uh you know keir has done a a a really
amazing job in turning that around in
getting the labour party back into a
position where we are taken seriously
again and people are listening to us
again and we're listening to to to the
public uh
again as well so
you know we don't take anything for
granted
we know it's a very very very tough uh
path to power for labour at the next
election
and given that as you say you know there
have been these huge big times of crisis
where
uh people expect uh politicians to sort
of lay down arms if you like and work
together which is what kier tried to do
through most of uh co-vidic which what
we're trying to do in terms of the
ukraine situation and so on i think to
have seen such a remarkable turnaround
in our fortunes in such a small space of
time i think is to key as a great credit
good to talk to you as always thanks
very much indeed for joining us thank
you
thank you